hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cell-based assays to functionally
characterize immunotherapy
and the immune response to viral
infection i am jennifer woods of lab
roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you want at any time you want during
the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker chris
langsdorff
staff scientist at thermo fisher
scientific
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
chris you may now begin your
presentation
great thank you for the introduction and
indeed thanks to lab roots
for hosting uh this webinar so it looks
like we have
quite a few people on on the line and
thanks to you all
for joining us i realize these are our
very busy times as we're getting back
into the lab and resuming our research
i know in our lab it's it's very busy as
we're
continuing to pick up a new projects and
so today we'll discuss a lot of our
research
specifically around two topics related
to immunology
first immunotherapy and second how we
can study the immune response to viral
infection
and especially looking at how we can use
cell-based assays
to study how viruses infect cells and
replicate now before we
begin i want to announce
the launch of a new website
that came out recently called the
immunology at work resource center
this is a free resource designed for
scientists of all levels to provide
an overview of immunology uh in all its
aspects
as foundational immunology different
immune cell subsets
viral immunity along with protocols
covering a lot of what i'll discuss
today
so this is meant for a a learning
resource for you
realizing that a lot of our our work has
pivoted
towards immunology in some aspects so
this provides a good overview of the
field
now for today uh and actually this
figure is drawn from the immunology at
work uh resource center
where uh in immunity we have a variety
of different cell types that protect us
either from cancerous cells or
from a pathogenic infection we can break
these down into
in both innate and adaptive cells and
functions
and today we'll discuss cells from from
both
of these compartments specifically we'll
focus
on natural killer cells and on t cells
and start out by looking at how these
two
types of lymphocytes are able to
function either in their natural setting
to target cancer cells as we see down
below through mhc complexes and
recognition of
presented peptides or up above
where we can reprogram these cells
either with chimeric antigen receptor t
cells or using therapeutic antibodies
against cancer cells
to encourage natural killer cells to
specifically
target and lyse cancer cells
and so we'll go over a range of
different protocols
for not only isolating these different
cell types
expanding their number in culture so you
have more to work with
and then matching up these immune cells
against various cancers
and show how we can study their behavior
and how we can modify that behavior
using
different therapeutics so let's start
off by looking at
t cells now t cells of course are
are easily obtained either from mouse or
human whole blood
very often these days we're working more
with human whole blood
so often what we prefer to do is from
whole blood we'll use
a density gradient to separate out the
peripheral blood mononuclear cells as
you see in the white layer here in this
centrifuge tube after we isolate those
pbmcs we can use a couple of different
approaches
to it then isolate our t cells shown
here on the right
are dyna beads untouched human t cells
now these contain
essentially tiny magnetic beads
and antibodies against every blood cell
type except for t
cells so essentially we will deplete
all of the cells in our blood except for
t cells
this becomes important if we would like
t cells that are not
activated but are isolated if we plan to
activate our t cells anyway
we can use something different this is
called the
cts dynabeads cd3cd28
now these are the same magnetic
beads except they're now coated with
antibodies against
human cd3 and cd28 so this will do two
things
first it will positively isolate t cells
from your pbmcs
based on the cd3 binding to this t
cell receptor second
after isolating the t cells this will
very aggressively activate and
expand meaning encourage our t cells to
proliferate
by means of cd3 antibody providing a
stimulatory signal
ncd 28 providing the co-stimulatory
signal
encouraging a robust
proliferation of our t cells
and so let me show you uh what this
actually looks like
in a cultured dish if we were to take
pvmcs
and use these cd3 and 28 dyna beads to
isolate t
cells and then just plate them here in a
t-75 flask
we can see the beads are not that much
smaller than a t-cell
we can easily visualize them both here
at 40x on our excel core microscope
now immediately after plating both of
these
components the beads and the cells will
settle to the bottom fairly quickly
and we can image them now if we were to
put these
in an incubator overnight and not
agitate them but just let them sit
we come back the next day and we can see
these clusters have formed
and this is due to beads binding to a
cell
and also binding to a neighboring cell
and that cell binding to
additional beads and essentially we see
these these clusters begin to form
if we come back and look the following
several days we see that these clusters
substantially increase in size uh and i
find this valuable because you can
actually see these without
even a microscope being required just by
eye you can see
these these aggregates
form and it tells you that it's working
it tells you that our t cells are
effectively
proliferating and we see this with
natural killer cells also
or with even car t cells we expect to
see the same thing
now this is not a spheroid or an
organoid by any means
it's just a loose association of cells
and so we can either swirl the media in
this plate
or we can use a very large pipet like a
25 mil
pipette and just aspirate up and down
the cells and media and it will disrupt
these structures
back to single cell suspension then we
can put these
in a conical tube in a magnet
and pull the beads out and what we're
left with
is purified and activated
and expanded human t cells
that we can take and put into our
downstream experiments
now at this point um you know in this
example these cells have been out of
a human now for five days and so we'd
like to do
a quick quality check to see
how healthy are they have they died or
are they viable
and are is it a good idea to carry these
on into our downstream assays
and so i'd like to announce um a new
instrument that will be launched
next week called the invitrogen countess
3
automated cell counter so this is the
third generation of a cell counting
device where
you can take 10 microliters of your cell
sample insert it into a small
plastic chip that you see in the middle
frame there
and within about 10 seconds you can get
a measurement of your cell concentration
and of percent live percent dead
or if they're labeled with any
fluorescent dye it can report
on the fluorescence intensity of single
cells as well
so this incorporates a lot of
new features better optics
better software machine learning
to help identify what is a cell and
what's not a cell
to give you more accurate results and so
this is something that i use
oh i don't know many times throughout
the day in the lab
at every step to to measure both
concentration and
viability of our cells concentration
measurement is useful
to report um to to better understand
how much our cells have proliferated
what the
fold expansion is but there are other
ways we can measure that
expansion or proliferation of ourselves
one very common method use a technique
called dye dilution
in which we will label cells and often
this is used with
t cells label cells with a very bright
dye which represents
the brightest uh farthest right peak
on this schematic of a fluorescence
histogram
now every time those t cells divide half
of the dye is passed to each daughter
cell
and so we see an additional peak on our
histogram
that is half as bright as the parent
peak
and so if our t cells were labeled with
dye such as a cell trace violet
and either left unstimulated or
stimulated in this case
with an antibody against cd3 and with
interleukin-2
we can see the appearance of in this
case 10 different
generations of cells so we can still
visualize our parent generation
and that unstimulated control is
valuable here so that we can see
where the parent generation is but now
we can actually characterize
the proliferation of ourselves and i've
included a
qr code here if you hold your phone in
front of it it will take you directly to
a good protocol for using cell trace
violet
to study expanded t cells
now increasingly
we're finding use for these cell trace
dyes
in other applications and one of those
is when we want to take
uh immune cells such as t cells or
natural killer cells
and combine them with a cancer cell so
that we'd like to study how they're
being killed and what we find is
in the case of mixing t cells with for
example a leukemia sample
they're they're very similar in size and
shape so
um they're difficult to identify which
cell is which
however if we were to pre-label both our
t
cells and in this case our target
leukemia cells
with different colors of cell tracing
dyes
and then mix them together we can now
see that
our um t cells
show up as blue and our cancer cells
show up as red
and so now we have a very simple potency
assay
where we can add a third reagent
called the cell event caspase-37 sensor
and now as our t-cells kill our cancer
cells the cancer cells will turn green
so we can observe this experiment over
time
and quantify or visualize our t
cells killing our target cancer cells
now often with this type of model flow
cytometry is preferred
to provide a quantitative single cell
analysis
of a lot of cells from a lot of
different samples
and so we can use this exact same model
with flow cytometry
to provide a good um high throughput
measurement of t cell killing
and so in this case we're doing the same
experiment where we're labeling
uh some k562 cells with our cell trace
violet dye and we'll mix them with t
cells and let them sit for one hour
and then we'll add a viability dye
called cytox deep red
this is a dye that shows up in your
sci-fi
channel and it will only enter
dead cells and make them show up very
brightly red
and so in this model we can
very easily put a gate on our cell trace
violet
positive cells to identify our cancer
cells and then we can just ask
how dead are those cells and in the
histogram on the right
we can see after only one hour almost
half
of those cells have been killed now
a couple of important things to note
about this setup
one is that we've chosen two very bright
dyes and so it's easy to set gates on
these
and then apply those gates to say 96
different samples and so that's where
high throughput analysis comes in
also we've done all of our cell labeling
during the assay so there's the end
point we just analyze
we're not doing any uh antibody labeling
or washing or fixing or perming
as soon as our hour is over we
put our sample into our attune nxt flow
cytometer and analyze
immediately and so we we can capture
accurately that
that endpoint and know that our time is
is correct now uh in this example we're
looking at t
cells killing one cell type
but we know increasingly in in
immunotherapy chimeric antigen receptor
t
cells are used because they can
specifically
target a t cell
to recognize cells expressing a given
antigen
and often this antigen is cd19 which is
expressed on both healthy b
cells and a variety of b-cell derived
cancers
and so what's important here is that not
only does the car t
cell specifically kill a target cell but
it does not
kill cells that lack that receptor so
it's a good
targeted therapy to study this we could
expand
the assay we've just described with an
additional color
so that we can use three colors of cell
trace dyes to label
each of these three populations of cells
then mix those three cell types together
and in this case we'll use
a different viability cytox green to
indicate
killing now importantly here
a few things to note about this brief
protocol
all of these cell trace dyes are
recommended
at somewhat higher concentrations around
5
micromolar we're doing a proliferation
analysis
in this example we want to use a much
lower concentration
i would use no more than one micromolar
or even
500 nanomolar die because these dyes are
so
bright it becomes hard to get them on
scale
so use a lower concentration of these
use a normal concentration of cytokines
green which is in the high nanomolar
also
then we'll just let these sit together
for eight hours
and then after eight hours in an
incubator we'll analyze
see what happens so we'll take this 96
well plate
directly out of the incubator put it
into our
tune nxt auto sampler and see what
results we get now important to point
out
we're using three different colors of
cell traced eyes
to label three different populations of
cells this gives us the ability to very
easily
distinguish cells from each other and
very clearly
and so with flow cytometry what we see
is
three different populations of cells on
the top
left we have our cd19 positive
population
on the bottom right is our cd19 negative
what we could
call the bystander population
now if we gate on our our target cells
and ask how live are they or to what
extent have they been killed
we can see that in this case 32 of those
cells
are dead at the end of this experiment
by comparison
our cd19 negative cells have
a significantly smaller fraction of
dead cells 9 and so we can see in this
example
that we can easily characterize the
viability and identity of different cell
types in this t cell killing assay
all right so we can move on now uh
beyond
t cells and look at
you know again many in the field are
pivoting from a focus
on
[Music]
the adaptive immune system and t cells
to the innate immune system and the
innate immune response to cancer
as um exemplified by natural killer
cells
now and k cells of course can also
act through a variety of activating and
inhibitory receptors
to both recognize and kill either cancer
cells or those cells infected
by a virus or we can use a therapeutic
antibody
to encourage those nk cells to bind and
kill and so a closer look at that model
if our cancer cell expresses a given
antigen and
we have a therapeutic antibody that
targets that antigen
importantly this should be a human
anti-human
or a humanized anti-human antibody
so that the cd16 or fc gamma receptor 3a
on our natural killer cells will bind
to that antibody and then specifically
kill our cancer cells
and so i'll show you a bit of detail on
how we study
this interaction and this mechanism of
immunotherapy but first
to briefly mention how we acquire
natural killer cells in the first place
and so much as we did with t cells let's
start with
peripheral blood mononuclear cells and
in this case we'll use
dynabeads untouched human nk cells
in this case you will take your pbmcs
at a very high concentration label them
with an antibody cocktail
and then after washing you'll add
functionalized dynabeads
which will bind and pull down or deplete
all of the other cells in your sample
i did this yesterday in our lab and it
takes about an hour
to produce unmodified untouched
human natural killer cells and so as you
see in this picture
if you choose to expand your natural
killer cells they will form these
cluster structures much as you do as
much as you see with
t cells so morphologically under a
microscope
at 40x they look quite similar to t
cells
however they do express a variety of
different
uh receptors um and so we may prefer
in this case we did um expand
our natural killer cells for 15 days and
we'd like to do a check of their their
viability and their phenotype
before studying their function and so
with flow cytometry this can easily be
done with
in this case a dye called cytox blue
and we can see that our natural killer
cells are
doing very well they're 98 live and then
as far as phenotype
we can see in this cell
population the vast majority express
cd56
and do not express cd3 and so we can say
this is quite a pure
and live population of human natural
killer cells
and so based on this we feel comfortable
carrying these cells forward
into a characterization assay
and so to do this we'll essentially
repeat
our car t killing protocol
with one slight modification and that is
we will add a therapeutic antibody
rituximab
which will bind to cd20 expressed on our
target cells
and our natural killer cells can bind to
that antibody
and specifically kill our cd20
expressing cells
but we expect these not to harm our
cells that lack that cd20 receptor
in this case this is a very potent
killing mechanism and so we're only
going to incubate for two hours before
analyzing and so much as we saw
previously
it's easy to identify our three
different cell types
and then to determine the percent of our
target
and our bystander cells that were killed
and so functionally this four color
panel is showing us that we can easily
identify our different cell types
and that we can characterize the killing
of one cell type by another
and so functionally everything looks
looks good here
um however we thought more about this
experiment and realized that
the natural killer cells we were using
are fresh from a human
you know just a few hours uh prior to
the assay
while the target and bystander cells in
this experiment
are are from a totally different human
and we're also lacking a lot of
components here these cells are not
in a human they're in in media and we're
missing a lot of cellular components
like
serum like all of the other immune cell
types that may contribute either via
cytokine signaling or direct signaling
to encourage these cells to kill so we
thought let's let's see if we can do the
same experiment
but let's do it in whole blood let's not
isolate out all of the different
cell fractions let's keep them intact
um and so let me show you how we we
accomplish this
um first some background on how this is
even possible
um because in whole blood
around less than less than one percent
or even 0.1 of the cells in our blood
are leukocytes the rest are erythrocytes
and those erythrocytes those red blood
cells can
obscure our analysis and indeed if we
run
whole blood through a capillary and take
a picture of it
even after some tenfold dilution
we see just this massive amount of cells
in a capillary
using a technique called acoustic
focusing we can use sound waves
ultrasonic sound waves which actually
exert a force on the cells
and gently push them into a single file
line
and so we can see that the focusing
works but this really doesn't benefit us
when we're trying to do
single cell analysis what we need to do
is
further dilute our sample 10-fold and
then use acoustic focusing
and now we even in whole blood we can
analyze one cell at a time as they pass
through our
interrogation point in a flow cytometer
unfortunately we have
a flow cytometer available with this
acoustic technology built in
called the attune nxt and as you see on
on the right
this instrument is 10 times faster
in terms of volume of sample per minute
than
other flow cytometers that are available
at the same time you can analyze
up to 14 colors on a four
laser instrument and so
um also for for high throughput
experiments
this year we launched the sitekick mix
auto sampler which will allow
the analysis of a 96 well plate in only
22 minutes
or a 384 well played in 88 minutes
so you see the the extra fluidic bottles
on the right here that help to enable
this
really dramatic increase in throughput
for the system of course this is
compatible
uh with our own uh lab automation
suite uh including robotics and
incubation and a fluidics cart
or it can integrate with with other uh
versions of of lab automation as needed
now anyway um if we were to analyze
um a sample of whole blood on the attune
uh and dilute that whole blood about 100
fold
into media and analyze them we can
analyze
single cells in whole blood the trouble
is
we now have so many erythrocytes that we
can't even visualize our lymphs
monos and grams
now fortunately the tune has a feature
by which we can use a special side
scatter kit
that we can detect side scatter on both
the violet laser
and on the blue laser and what we're
doing here is
is taking advantage of the fact that our
red blood cells absorb
light in the violet range of the
spectrum around 405 nanometers
and so without any label required just
based on the intrinsic absorbance of
light
by our erythrocytes we can see two
populations of cells here
one being this very large population of
red blood cells in a smaller population
above
of white blood cells and so if
we we can prove that these are
white blood cells by labeling whole
blood
with a dye that binds dna in
live cells and so by using dye cycle
violet we can see a positive population
here
that is less than one percent that
represents all cells with a nucleus our
erythrocytes lack a nucleus and so we
see
their dim on this histogram so if we get
on the positive cells we can prove to
ourselves that
in fact these are leukocytes that we're
visualizing
now with flow cytometry we have the
ability to set a fluorescence threshold
and teach our instrument to essentially
ignore cells in this case that lack
a nucleus and so we can now analyze
whole blood by flow cytometry but only
capture events if they contain a nucleus
and so we can build on this and now uh
attempt to incorporate our immune cell
killing assay
by in whole blood um and so
here's a brief protocol for how we
accomplish this
we published this about a year ago but
the the brief version is let's take
our cancer cell line in this case romo
cells
and we'll label them with cell trace
deep red then we'll take 100 000 of
those cells at 10 to the 7th per mil
and spike them into only 5 microliters
of whole blood
and a final concentration of 10
nanomolar
rituximab for a total volume of 25
microliters per well
and as you see here on the right
if we now allow this to incubate
for two hours we will then
add a very substantial amount of media
two mills of media per well
this is possible because we're using a
deep well
dish where each well holds 2 milliliters
of
volume and so essentially we're diluting
our whole blood
about you know 500 fold
by the time it's analyzed now we'll add
a viability die cytox green
as we've discussed previously and
dicycle violet
which will allow us to threshold only on
nucleated cells
then we'll take this plate put it into
our tune nxt
autosampler and analyze every well at
500 microliters per minute
which is about depending on the
instrument five to ten times faster than
other
flow cytometers are capable of analyzing
and so we can get through this entire
plate actually very quickly
and so what do we see as a result of
this
well first we're able to effectively
identify only nucleated cells and again
ignore our erythrocytes and then
because we pre-labeled our cancer cells
with a tracking dye
we can easily and clearly resolve our
target cells
from the white blood cells that are
native in that cell population
and so then the next question we wanted
to ask is how
viable are the target cells were they
killed during this two hours of sitting
in whole blood and the answer to that is
yes they were very substantially killed
we see 54
of dead cells as reported by cybox green
and so again we can clearly identify our
target and our
our native white blood cells and we can
very clearly see
our live and our dead cell populations
and if you like we can combine this into
a single
dual parameter plot where we can see
this
very large population of dead target
cells it's also important to note that
our
white blood cells are not dead and
they're
very live and healthy after two hours of
incubation in this experiment
and so our next question was were these
cells killed
as a result of the therapeutic antibody
that we added encouraging the
killing by both natural killer cells and
by complement proteins in our whole
blood
the answer to that is yes if we leave
out
that therapeutic antibody the rituximab
as shown on the bottom
our dead cell population essentially
vanishes so it's only with an
appropriate dose
of rituximab that we see that killing
and indeed that entire 96 well plate was
a dose response experiment
to characterize what concentration of
this antibody
is required to encourage um
in this case probably an innate immune
response
by the components of that whole blood
most likely driven by complement
proteins
natural killer cells and potentially
some neutrophils as well
so now this this type of model uh
where we're not just characterizing
the killing of cells but we're trying to
make it as physiologically
relevant as as possible we're hoping
this will help
to better predict the
the functioning in vivo of of
therapeutics
so a lot more work is being done on on
this
kind of model system to study killing in
whole blood
but we also realize that you know
approximately 10 percent of all cancers
are blood cancers or liquid tumors you
could call them
the rest are solid cancers solid
tumors and so for this this type of
model we need a different model system
and often fluorescence microscopy is
used for that
so we can use a similar setup
to study in this case the killing of
breast cancer cells by natural killer
cells
again we've labeled our human primary
natural killer cells with a tracking dye
so we can see them
as blue when we add these to our
skbr3 cells in the presence of
herceptin we can see that our breast
cancer cells
turn from green to a very bright red
as they're killed and this is using a
system called the live dead cell imaging
kit
with two components a green dye that
labels
our live cells and then as those cells
die the green signal is lost in a very
bright
red signal appears and so
functionally we can see that our nk
cells are able to act in an antibody
mediated manner
to kill breast cancer cells to to target
and kill a solid tumor model but again
we we'd like to make this a more
physiologically relevant model
so we can pivot from two dimensions into
a three-dimensional model
simply by growing our cells in a special
kind of
dish called nunclon sphera microplates
which in this case we've added 5 000
cells per well and incubate it overnight
and we see the presence of 96 uniform
spheroids
and we can now add our natural killer
cells
to each of these spheroids either in the
absence of oxidizing antibody
or in the presence of cetuximab an iegf
receptor antibody
and we can see in the left panel in
green
we have a few dead cells the middle
panel when we add our natural killer
cells we can see that they have
penetrated
into this tumor spheroid but there's not
much killing that has happened
in the panel on the right if we add our
cetuxumab our
specific antibody then we see a dramatic
increase in our green signal
and we can actually quantify this and
not only qualitatively but
quantitatively study
the killing of solid tumors by natural
killer cells
so we've looked at a range of different
um anti-tumor or anti-cancer
immunity mechanisms and a range of
different
biologies um but i'd like to pivot now
because while t cells and nk cells
are are very effective at targeting
cancer cells
they also um are
professionally uh cells that
professionally target
virus infected cells and so
uh not in a in a um a
drug mediated fashion but just by the
biology of the cells they're able to
target cells in which
viruses have infected and so
uh look briefly at some some different
mechanisms
different methods we can use to study
this process of
viral infection first we can look
briefly at how viruses are able to
enter cells and begin the replication
process
different viruses are bind and enter
cells through different routes
sometimes this can be through direct
fusion
with the host cell membrane or through
binding to a cell surface receptor
followed by
endocytosis and various viruses will
be released from this endocytic pathway
at different stages so
either in the early endosome or late
endosome
or lysosome depending on the specific
biology of a given virus
now it's important to note that this
pathway is an acidic pathway
so viruses outside the cell are in a
neutral ph environment
as they enter an endosome they become
acidified and as they progress
to a late endosome or a lysosome that ph
can drop
down to around four and so we can take
advantage of that
to study the uptake and endocytosis and
maturation of
viral particles so in one example if we
take
enterovirus and label it with a ph
sensitive dye
called frodo ifl green the stp ester is
an amine reactive version of this dye
if you label a virus with this dye it
will be a non-fluorescent outside a cell
but it will become very brightly
fluorescent as its
endocytosed and as it progresses along
that endocytic
pathway and so the fluorescent signal
by the dye gives us a quantitative
measure of how
far into a cell that virus has
progressed
and in this case a drug treatment is
being used to inhibit
acidification of that pathway so we can
see some panels
where the signal is less bright now
we can perform a quantitative analysis
with the same type of ph sensitive dye
in this case using rio virus
labeled with the red version so frodo
ifl red
stp ester was used to label this virus
then it was added to hela cells for the
indicated times in this chart
and then with flow cytometry we can just
ask
how bright is each cell in that red
channel
and as we see in our
photo labeled and treated channel our
mean fluorescence intensity increases
quite substantially
you know three to four fold brighter
while if ammonium chloride is used to
alkalinize
those compartments our signal remains
minimal
and so using this this approach we can
effectively track the internalization of
cell viruses into cells so after
internalization
we'd like to study the encoding and
replication of viruses in host cells
now um there
has been some some uh a lot of mention
in uh
both the media and in scientific
literature this year of
a compound called rendezvous it is
actually a pro drug
uh when this is metabolized in humans or
in cells it becomes an active
metabolite as shown here in the middle
um this is not
uh too different from the nucleoside
adenosine
one of the four four bases
that is contained in uh uh
incorporated into replicating dna um
they're um are i guess i should should
call out that
this active metabolite functions by
once three or four copies of it are
incorporated into
an elongating rna template or a
transcript
it will interrupt that
that process and effectively block
the formation of that nascent transcript
we can make additional nucleoside
modifications
we can modify uridine with a handle as
shown on the very top right and a final
handle
and create 5-thinol uridine
now in this case this very small tag
will
be incorporated into actively
produced rna however it will not
inhibit the ability of that rna to be
produced
what it does is gives us a very small
tag that if we are to
feed this to our cells
this will be incorporated into nascent
rna
then we can use a a click reaction to
click on an
azide diconjugate in this case using an
alexa floor dye
and so after incubating our cells with
this compound we can fix
and perm and perform a click reaction
and then
in the image on the right we can
visualize uh
locations of active rna production
and so as shown by the the bright
magenta
we can actually visualize where in this
case
um rna is produced by our mammalian
cells
this can become valuable for studying
the transcription
of viral rna if we treat our host cells
with the compound actinomycin d
which inhibits the cellular dna
dependent
rna transcription and so in this case
we're only visualizing a synthesis
of coronavirus rna in host cells by the
rna-dependent rna polymerase so we can
see over time
that this coronavirus is very rapidly
producing its own
rna and we see the nucleus is dark
because we have
blocked the ability of the the host cell
to
transcribe its own rna
we can transition this into a
multiplex experiment uh combined with
antibodies against
the coronavirus non-structural protein
12
and an antibody against double-stranded
rna
and as you see in the bottom insets we
can begin to co-localize
foci of viral rna
production the viral protein and
double-stranded rna in the same place
and so
while this is reporting specifically the
production of
virus rna it's not actually reporting
any specific template the rna that
encodes any specific protein
so we can do that but using a different
method
for imaging we would call this view rna
cell plus
and in a zika virus model we can use
an antibody against tubulin and use
um our view rna cell plus to visualize
these
on the bottom right uh bright
spots uh indicating zika virus rna
localization
now for for imaging this is called view
rna
cell plus for flow we call this the
prime flow rna assay and this is
compatible
uh with both immuno phenotyping and a
range of other
functional dyes such as viability so
for example using an hiv model we can
use a standard
gating scheme to identify our live
helper t cells as shown in this
sequence and then in those live helper t
cells
we can ask how much hiv one
rnas present in each of those a variety
of different samples and we can see
the bottom right of each of these
density plots we can we can identify
a very small subset of our helper t
cells that actually contain
hiv-1 rna so now we're detecting a
specific
transcript unique to a given virus
that's contained within a host cell
so not the total presence of the virus
but the presence of an
individual rna transcript
now with prime flow there are you know
thousands of different
targets available off the shelf and one
of the newest
is to specifically detect the sars cov2
rna in infected cells so uh we
recently released a probe set specific
to this
uh that covers multiple regions of the
sars kobe 2
transcript so there's a link here at the
bottom that will direct you to that
but we find this is a very powerful
method to characterize
the interaction of viruses with host
cells so this
and many of the other things that i
described today
are available through the immunology at
work resource
center uh the protocols i mentioned
today
for both isolating expanding and
characterizing the function of these
immune cells are available here
some other great features um one that i
personally use quite often
on the right is the immune cell guide
which breaks down all of the different
immune cell subsets
and what cd markers they express either
in a resting or
in an activated state that becomes quite
helpful for for building panels
there's a qr code at the bottom if you
scan it with your
phone it will take you directly to that
website
and so i'd encourage you to to take
advantage of
this resource we will keep this up to
date as the field
continues to um evolve but it's meant as
a resource
for you to continue uh learning in this
area
so i realized these are busy times as
we're approaching the end of the year so
i want to thank you for spending
this hour with us to focus on both
anti-cancer immunity and on antiviral
immunity so thank you for joining us and
i think now we have plenty of time left
to take any questions you have so thank
you
thank you chris for your informative
presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so our first question is
do you have nk cell expansion from mouse
yes so the next thanks for the question
um
the dynamics are also available for
mouse models as well so either t or nk
or monocytes there's a variety of
different ones available
for human or mouse and they're a
research grade
and also a cts meaning a cell therapy
approved grade of those beats
okay thank you chris our next question
how do you activate these human nk cells
yeah so nk cells uh we can activate with
just il2
or we can more specifically activate
them uh
you know to to make them think that
they're
targeting different cell types or viral
infected cells with a variety of other
cytokines
so those protocols have been built into
the
immunology at work resource center and
so really the
there's a lot of detail there on what
cytokine might be appropriate for what
model depending on
how you're planning to use your nk cells
thanks for the question
our next question what culture media
system do you use to culture your nk
cells
oh good question also because um that's
one that
there is less available uh in the
literature about what is a good media
firm for nk cells
you know of course there's the optimizer
media that's very widely used for t
cells for nk cells again there is a
media recipe called out
specifically in one of the protocols in
that immunology resource center
that's you know based on just rpmi or
there's you can use aim five as well
it's a bit
of a legacy system uh we are working
on a much better system and
and so again hopefully we'll see some
innovation in that space
soon but for now the the recipe that we
used
is fully available in protocol in that
resource center
great thank you chris okay our next
question
do target cells leak cell tracing die
after killing
yeah so that's an insightful question uh
the the cell trace dies
uh they label proteins in the target
cells and so they're very stable
very well retained over time and
actually
cfsc used to be used for this but we
found that that
would leak out quite rapidly over time
the newer colors of cell trace dyes are
much more well retained so you get
stable fluorescent signal over time
so immediately after killing the signal
should be unchanged
however if your cells that are being
killed actually start to bleb and fall
apart
those blebs will still be fluorescent
you can still see those
by flow cytometry so essentially what
you'll see is your your target cell
will begin to shrink or become less
bright but you can still identify it
okay great our next question do these
dyes affect cell growth
oh yeah so great question also so that
was something during the testing of
these
and again we'll refer back to cfse which
is a legacy dye that's now
26 years old but widely used but that
does
affect the ability of cells to grow it
can be toxic
so during the development of the cell
trace dyes meaning
the violet far red and yellow
we screen those to see if they are toxic
and
so we we launch those on the basis that
they're not toxic to cells so they're
not going to affect the ability of your
cells to proliferate
if you're using some really sensitive
cell type
i would recommend using a lower
concentration of those cells
so sorry those dyes one micro molar
or less to to really be sure that uh
it's not having an impact
so yeah thanks another very good
question
our next question any tools for human
gamma delta t cells isolation or
expansion
uh yes you know definitely i think
um as far as isolation of those uh
sometimes this just comes down to
sorting with facts
uh you know antibody based immuno
phenotyping followed by sorting
uh if there's a specific
combination of antibodies that you can
identify
it might be possible to cobble together
your own
bead-based isolation but generally for
these
smaller subsets of cells
we've called out in pretty good detail
actually in the immunology at work
resource center how to identify things
like gamma deltas
you know what markers are appropriate
and if you are going to sort these with
the facts what some considerations are
for both isolation and
growth of those cells
all right thank you so much we have
another question here
can the inblood adcc be run on a more
basic cytometer
that does not have the 405 nanometer ssc
yeah that's a good point the um so the
whole blood
immune self killing um essay we showed
it on the attune
um it now um
there are other instruments that are
able to look at side scatter with 405
and that's just one way to do it you can
also use
just a dicycle violet or another
live cell dna die to label nucleated
cells
and then you can just gate on that
population and
use that approach to ignore erythrocytes
the trouble is you need throughput
because
red blood cells are such a large
fraction of your whole blood
you really need the throughput of
theotune to make this a practical assay
so that you can actually analyze enough
cells in a reasonable amount of time
especially if you're doing a dose
response curve or something like i
showed so yes it's definitely possible
on other instruments
um it's just not it's much more
practical if you have access to a team
awesome okay next question can we use
cd 28 dyna dynabeads to check the
activation of til
um to check the activation of til
um so
assume meaning tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes that are potentially
potentially isolated from a human tumor
um the dyna beads uh the
first example that i showed for for
isolating t
cells yeah those would be great for
pulling tills
out of a dissociated human tumor trying
to isolate tills
uh in fact we have one that is cv3 cd28
and cd137 so you can start to
you know more accurately isolate
activated t cells or
better activate them um so
i would suggest that um the diabetes
could be good for
pulling t cells out specifically tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes
out of a lysed uh tumor
um but not so much to detect
activated cells for that we'd probably
use a variety of antibodies against
things like cd5 cd69
uh or potentially the expression of
cytokines in those cells
so yeah thank you okay
another question can cell trace dye
be used with calcine
sure yeah and that that combination
where uh calcium
is is usually referring to calcium green
and it's a dye that
i showed during the nk example
that was the diet that turned those live
cells green
you could envision a good assay
combination where you label
you know one population of cells with a
cell trace die
and then you interrogate killing
you know as as um the perforin and
granzyme
in your t cells or your natural killer
cells lyse the target cells the calcium
will leak out
and so there are some some
considerations there
some cancer cells incorrectly turn on a
membrane pump that pumps calcium out
and so you need to check and see if that
exists in your model
it's also exists in stem cells and so
there are some some things to be aware
of with calcium but it can become a
valuable part of an assay when you
combine the cell trace dyes
we have another question looks like we
have time for just a few more
do you have any dyna beads to isolate
platelets
you know that's a good question
it's not my area of expertise and so
i'd have to to look and get back to you
on that
we do have the ability with the attune
you know where where i showed you
the uh erythrocyte population and the
leukocyte population
in that scatter that density plot you
can actually see
platelets there as well so you're able
now to directly
analyze platelets you know they might be
labeled with cd41
or markers but you don't so much need to
pull them
down anymore you can directly analyze
them on that instrument
great we've got one more question can
prime flow be used to detect only
specific rna transcripts or any target i
want
oh yeah so the the prime flow method to
detect specific transcripts in
in cells uh we have a wide range of
existing
uh targets that are available but if you
have something specific
like you're looking uh to study the the
rna synthesis of something that you've
built like a chimeric antigen receptor
in your cells
we can custom make a probe set for for
whatever you need
so there's a resource on
thermofisher.com where you can
either search everything that's
available off the shelf or if you need
something custom made
we can certainly do that for you
recommended recommend
the best route to make that successful
for you
so thank you thank you chris do you have
any final comments for our audience
sure um yeah i want to thank everyone
for for joining us
today during these busy times
and uh do want to mention uh two things
one i encourage you to
uh to follow up and visit the immunology
at work
resource center and take advantage of
you know most of the questions that were
asked today
have an answer somewhere in there
whether it's a protocol
or a media type and also to call out
that in two weeks on november 17th
we have another webinar coming up with
sarah dibiase
talking about sars covi2 infection
how that's studied in cells specifically
using the attune
nxt cytometer so uh i'll
i'll plan to see everyone there in
in two weeks and we'll see enjoy sarah's
presentation
so thank you everyone for joining us
today
thank you again chris for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye